what's the question
um how do you feel about um the topic of
the show like um modern women having
unrealistic expectations in dating yeah
like uh yeah so there's quite a few
things that went on I wanted to pick on
them so I probably forgot a few of them
but I just think uh modern women
like I said they have when she was
saying in regards to having high
standards for yourself and not wanting
to settle I just think it's not about
having setting your standards or setting
this is just your level and a lot of
women don't realize what the level is so
um I do believe a man's supposed to be a
provider I do believe a man is supposed
to protector I do believe a man is
supposed to pay for bills I do believe a
man is supposed to to basically so I
haven't been on your on your show before
I've obviously been on Pearl show so
I'll just tell a little bit about myself
um I have three sisters all over the
child they're all married
um my mum and dad I've been married for
over 40 years my dad's achieve um also a
professor I'm quite educated I come from
Cameroon as a diplomat my brother's also
married as well I'm the only one that's
actually not married currently now so I
come from that from from that um
demographic and that upbringing so for
me it's always been about being a
protective woman but the problem is a
lot of women don't understand that if a
man is going to protect you you need to
trust in his leadership and Trust in his
leadership which means having not having
to listen but trusting someone his
leadership is sometimes even when you
don't agree you know what I'm gonna go
with you and I think in regards to you
you found a man who you could trust in
his leadership and even if he didn't
make the money or if you lost the money
you could look inside him and say he'll
make it again because he's that type of
man so I think
I don't have any problem with women one
enough to do traditional roles but I
they have to be traditional women and
when I said that you're not a virgin
whatever obviously you were when you got
married a lot of women aren't but that's
not important if what is important you
don't want to go with a high body count
I'm an agreeable attitude but if you
have been there then at least when you
come and meet a man you should be
agreeable and you should kind of get on
this page so when men are when we say
things like oh we don't want you going
to certain places or hanging around or
having male friends orbiters is not
because we're insecure it's not because
we control it's because we love you and
that sort of Love sometimes we haven't
felt that before it's always associating
with some type of misogyny and stopping
them doing things but us as Menace
protectors we can see things and dangers
that you cannot see and a lot of the
times when you're talking about even
having those whole friends or those
friends that a little bit outside but
you're like she's my girl she's my girl
that girl can put you in situations and
things that you know what I mean which
which you don't actually want to be in
there so I think when you have a if you
want a man a lot of times these women
they want to have a they want to have
the cake and eat it raw so I just think
if you want to be outside be outside but
if you want to have the protection of a
man and you know this 50 50 thing I know
you're saying you're going to go
downstairs but you don't want to go
downstairs you want your man to go
downstairs and I want him to go
downstairs do you understand so 50 50 a
lot of the times see in the past year
okay cool we could probably survive on
one wage and a lot of times women talk
about six figures I'll be honest with
you I've met more women that earn six
figures from a drum that I've earned
that I've met men but I know more men
that I've made six figures from having
businesses and stuff so this thing where
you're gonna walk up to man and he's and
he's got job of six figures especially
within the community and demographic
you're talking about it's unrealistic
right okay but if you can understand the
types of men that you're dealing with
and get on their page then money should
have never mattered all all that matter
was a man had good promise your father
checked him over your brother checked
him over and he said listen you're gonna
come with me I'm gonna go and get on
this thing where you attach
um finance and wealth to how much
someone loves you it's a dangerous thing
to do because a lot of girls meet these
guys with money need more money than
sense and because he splashes money on
you you consider this to be something
where he loves me but then he'll drop
you again you understand but the man
that's actually you don't see the guy
that's working in Tesco stacking up the
shelves who's actually a good man who's
studying who's got a plan you don't want
to give him an opportunity because he's
not that guy yet so you know the way I
look at relationships is me as a man I'm
a provider
um I'll you know I believe a man like
all my family I would die for die for my
woman that's what we're supposed to do
but we cannot die for a woman that won't
listen to us or trust in our leadership
and trusted in someone's leadership is
the ultimate
um for me it's the ultimate proof of
love I I totally agree I totally agree
we said um I think that most men do want
to protect and provide for a woman that
they trust they trust that this is a
loyal woman she's on my team like
there's no shadow of a doubt because if
there's no shadow of a doubt you jump in
front of the bullet there's there's no
no second guessing there's no second
thought yeah you get what I'm saying but
again like just like what you said I
think there's a lot of women out there
that want their cake and eat it she's
not saying I want to be 50 50 but I want
to be a princess but I want to be a
princess and I want 55th bro it don't go
like that probably it doesn't it doesn't
bro there's no two captains of the ship
there's one captain on the ship right
you can be the first mate and yeah I
will listen to what you got to say but
the final decision of where we're going
and I'm holding the compass is on me in
it because if this ship sinks bro it's
on me bro yeah but I'm saying yeah so
like just what you're saying like I
think it's just it seems to be an honest
put-on if a woman
if a woman listens to a man or or you
know he he tells her what to do it's a
thing where she hasn't got her own mind
I just want to let ladies know there's a
lot of power and femininity and I think
just like this power in positive
masculinity there's a lot of power and
femininity so for me by you acting in
your feminine and doing certain things
you will get every single thing you want
there's some having just noticed there's
some girls that just get everything like
have you noticed they're just some girls
that men just get them everything like
they don't get them everything because
they argue with them and unagreeable no
they get them everything because these
women actually inspire these men to go
more do you know what it is like when
you so this so you can have your bridges
that gonna support you I'm gonna tell
you boy you can make it you can do this
thing yeah that's that's a power your
family that's a power but when you're
waking up next to a woman and she's
telling you babes you know you know you
can do this when you've lost money when
you don't know how you're going to pay
the rent but she's even saying don't
worry I know you're gonna pay the rent
and something goats and the call happens
and then this move happens and then
you're able to make some money you're
like wow I didn't even believe that but
she believed that there's something
powerful in in building something
together
thank you so even earlier when you were
saying what you were saying I really
liked it because I've been on here a few
times and all I get is the women that
they don't prescribe yeah so for me is
like you can pick a man now
and look at him and he might not be
nothing but He's got potential right and
you can ride with that potential that
you No One Ever Knows what's gonna
happen right but or you can pick a man
that's already made it and now you
become one of his options and because
you've come at such a later stage you
don't have somebody you don't have some
of the you know I mean the power and a
lot of women think that us men will
leave you we won't leave you if you if
you're there from the start we will not
leave you like is it some it's some
crazy notion that women create in their
head that always say this though
you know ride or die like you was with
the hard times like bro he's not Gonna
Leave You Hand Dry he's not bro like no
like I said if I had if I had a wife and
she had my babies and then she got and
she got fat I would obviously try to
take her to the gym I tried to do all
the type of stuff but I'm not gonna
leave her bro yeah absolutely you know
what it is now I've got a fat wife would
be looking at old pictures for how we
used to look that's it like because end
of the day it comes like when a man
picks a woman and a real man picks a
woman because this thing where like I
don't so most women leave men right we
know that already but there's some men
that leave they women and I hate these
types of men for me these men are the
worst types of men they scumbags bro
like because I can't be out here trying
to Champion for men and the men actually
leaving their wife like or leaving the
girl after she had the you bro like I
think it's crazy men are breaking up
their families bro like and and as much
as I'm gonna obviously tell women about
you you shouldn't be leaving your man
and you should work through things
there's actually men that's breaking up
their families bro to get me I don't
respect these men like like and we don't
support these men bro like no no I get I
get that like yeah absolutely agree with
that like I think especially for a lot
of us guys from my community that grew
up without dads I feel like a lot of us
we have that razor sharp focus of like
if I have a kid I'm gonna be in that
kid's life that kid ain't gonna live the
kind of Life I Lived do you get what I'm
saying so I I think that goes without
saying so yeah like if you go if you
shoot up the club bro yeah like fam look
after your kid [ __ ] because you know
how it feels bro like do you get what
I'm saying even if you don't want to be
with the woman I understand sometimes
it's a Madness in it but you better look
after that kid bro you know what I'm
saying like it's serious we've all seen
the repercussions of that incarceration
drug abuse runaways all kinds of essay
all this kind of nonsense bro like get
me don't put your kid at risk in it as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible